this is not a guy who's going to be like
it's a good thing that Western forces
are taking over our country he thinks
it's a horrible thing Constantine kiss
and translated his speech which everyone
should check out on Twitter it's a long
thread and Putin was essentially
intimating that the liberal economic
order has gone too far it's destroying
Earth it's creating you know it's
satanic I think he even said at one
point and he will it's going it's
falling and he won't it's he's going to
make sure that it falls right he said
the Satanism thing in line with the
gender Idol ideology that's going to be
pushed and I actually watched leninoff
at the un uh in the previous week and it
was hard for me to dis I'm no roosophile
right I agree with you Tim that Putin's
not a great guy he's got his mindset he
has author authoritarianism but when you
have leninoff sitting there talking
about the war on terror what we did in
Afghanistan Iraq Libya Somalia and
Beyond it's hard to argue with the guy
what Freedom did we bring you know are
these nation states better off after our
intervention or are they worse off